OF INVESTIGATIONS INTO GROSS
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, CNN HAS
INTERVIEWED A FORMER MEMBER OF
CHINESE SECURITY FORCES WHO
TELLS CNN HE WAS ROUTINELY
ORDERED TO ARREST AND TORTURE
UIGHUR DETAINEES IN TRULY
HORRIFIC AND BARBARIC WAYS.
CHINA DENIES ACCUSATIONS FROM
THE UNITED STATES THAT IT'S
DETAINED UP TO 2 MILLION
UIGHURS, MANY OF THEM MUSLIM IN
A SYSTEM OF MODERN-DAY
INTERNMENT CAMPS IN THE XINJIANG
REGION.
IVAN WATSON BRINGS US THESE
DISTURBING REVELATIONS AND WE
WANT TO WARN OUR VIEWERS IT
CONTAINS GRAPHIC DESCRIPTIONS OF
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
>> PUSH THE ELECTRIC STICK HERE
AND IT'S JUST LIKE BURNING.
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE STORY
OF A VICTIM AND A SELF-CONFESSED
TORTURURE.
>> DO THE POLICE OFFICERS USE
ELECTRIC BATONS TO SHOCK
PRISONERS?
>> Translator: YES.
EVERYONE USES DIFFERENT METHODS.
>> Reporter: FOR YEARS, STORIES
OF ARBITRARY ARRESTS,
UNSPEAKABLE CRUELTY AND MASS
INTERNMENT CAMPS HAVE BEEN
TRICKLING OUT OF CHINA'S
XINJIANG REGION.
TESTIMONY FROM PEOPLE LIKE
ABDUELI.
WHEN YOU WERE DETAINED, WHAT WAS
YOUR MAIN JOB?
>> KINDERGARTEN TEACHER.
>> Reporter: POLICE TOOK HIM
FROM HIS UIGHUR LANGUAGE
KINDERGARTEN.
>> BLACK HOOD ON MY FACE.
THE INTERROGATION ROOM.
AND INSIDE THERE'S A -- YOU ARE
SHACKLED THERE AND LIKE YOUR
FEET ARE SHACKLED.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS POLICE
ACCUSED HIM OF ESPIONAGE,
PLOTTING AGAINST THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT AND THE CRIME OF
SEPARATISM.
AND THEY DEMANDED A CONFESSION.
>> YOU JUST CONFESS.
YOU JUST ADMIT WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE.
IT'S GOOD FOR YOU.
>> Reporter: NOW FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME, CNN HAS SPOKEN TO A
FORMER CHINESE POLICE OFFICER
WHO CLAIMS HIS JOB WAS TO ARREST
AND EXTRACT CONFESSIONS FROM
ETHNIC UIGHURS IN XINJIANG.
>> Translator: SOME COPS WOULD
PLAY THE GOOD COPS AND SOME
WOULD PLAY THE BAD COPS.
AFTER WE BEAT THEM, WE'D OFFER
THEM A CIGARETTE.
>> Reporter: DID YOU HAVE TO BE
THE BAD COP SOMETIMES?
>> Translator: OF COURSE.
>> Reporter: THE MAN WHO ASKS TO
BE CALLED JANG SAYS HE WORKED
MORE THAN TEN YEARS AS A COP
BEFORE FLEEING CHINA AFTER
GROWING DISILLUSIONED WITH THE
RULING COMMUNIST PARTY.
I MET HIM IN A JUNIOR COUNTRY.
HE WORE HIS POLICE UNIFORM TO
AUTHENTICATE HIS STORY BUT DOES
NOT WANT TO BE IDENTIFIED TO
PROTECT HIMSELF AND RELATIVES
WHO
>> TO PROVE THAT HE WAS A
CHINESE POLICE OFFICER, JANG IS
SHOWING ME MANY PHOTOS OF
DIFFERENT POLICE BADGES AND
TRAINING CERTIFICATES AND EVEN
PORTRAITS OF HIS GRADUATING
CLASS AT POLICE ACADEMY.
IMAGES THAT WE CANNOT SHOW ON
TELEVISION BECAUSE THEY WOULD
REVEAL HIS IDENTITY HE SAID HE
WAS SENT FROM HIS HOME TO WORK
IN SHIN JANG THREE TIMES DURING
WHICH HE WAS ORDERED TO ARREST
HUNDREDS OF SUSPECTS, ALL OF
THEM ETHNIC UYGHURS.
>> HOW WERE THE INTERROGATIONS
BEING CONDUCTED.
>> BEAT THEM, KICK THEM.
BEAT THEM BRUISED AND SWOLLEN.
KNOCK THEIR HEADS ON THE
RADIATOR.
>> SOME WERE AS YOUNG AS 14 AND
ALL DETAINEES WERE BEATEN.
>> WERE THE SUSPECTS ALL MEN?
>> MEN AND WOMEN.
>> DID YOU WITNESS WOMEN BEING
BEATEN?
>> YES.
>> CNN CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRM THE ALLEGATIONS NOR
THOSE OF THE KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER WHO SAID IN ADDITION TO
BEAT EGGS, HE WAS RAPED ON HIS
FIRST NIGHT OF DETENTION BY
CHINESE PRISONERS WHO FOLLOWED
THE ORDERS OF PRISON GUARDS.
>> THIS WAS PRISONERS WHO
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED YOU?
>> YES.
>> PRISONERS?
MORE THAN ONE.
>> JUST FIRST OF ALL, THEY
SURROUNDED ME AND THE POLICE
THERE ORDERED ME TO TAKE OFF MY
UNDERWEAR AND LET ME --
>> AND BEND OVER.
DON'T DO THIS.
I CRIED.
PLEASE DON'T DO THIS.
AND THEN LIKE ONE -- I DON'T
KNOW HELD MY HAND LIKE THIS.
>> Reporter: THE POLICE OFFICER
WHO FLED CHINA DESCRIBED IN
DETAIL METHOD OF SEXUAL TORTURE
THAT HE SAID POLICE OFFICERS
USED.
>> Translator: IF YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO CONFESS, YOU USE THE
ELECTRIC BAT ON AND SET THE
WIRES ON THE GENITALS WHILE THE
PERSON IS TIED UP.
THE RESULT IS BETTER.
>> Reporter: AND POLICE
SOMETIMES ORDERED PRISONERS TO
SEXUALLY ASSAULT DETAINEES.
>> WE CALL IT AN IN PRISON
INVESTIGATION.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE BATTLING
VIOLENT EXTREMISM IN SHING JANG
AND THEY DENY THAT ANYTHING IS
HAPPENING THERE.
>> AND THE GENOCIDE IS A RUMOR
BACKED BY ULTERIOR MOTIVES AND
AN OUTRIGHT LIE.
>> BUT THE COP SAID HE GOT
DOUBLE HIS NORMAL SALARY TO JOIN
TENS OF THOUSANDS SENT THERE AS
PART OF THE GOVERNMENT
CRACKDOWN.
>> HOW MANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU ARREST DO YOU THINK WERE
ACTUALLY VIOLENT EXTREMISTS?
>> NONE.
>> SHIN JANG IS NOT A WAR ZONE
AND THOSE PEOPLE ARE OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS, NOT FOREIGN ENEMIES.
>> IF YOU DIDN'T CARRY OUT THE
ARREST, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
YOU?
>> THEN I WOULD BE ARRESTED AS
WELL BECAUSE I'M TOO AM PART OF
A TERRORIST ORGANIZATION.
I BECOME THEIR ENEMY.
>> Reporter: AFTER 15 MONTHS IN
DETENTION HE CONFESSED TO
ILLEGAL FUNDRAISING AND WAS
RELEASED AND LATER FLED CHINA.
SINCE THEN SEVERAL OF HIS
RELATIVES HAVE BEEN DETAINED
INCLUDING HIS NIECE.
>> WHERE WAS YOUR NIECE HELD?
>> THE SAME FACILITY I STAYED.
I DON'T KNOW HOW SHE DIED.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
SHE IS THE FIRST ONE, FIRST BABY
THAT I HOPE.
SHE'S JUST LIKE MY DAUGHTER.
ZBRFRMT.
>> Reporter: SP TONS TO WRITTEN
QUESTIONS THEY DENY THAT SHE
DIED IN DETENTION SAYING THE
30-YEAR-OLD WOMAN INSTEAD DIED
OF ORGAN FAILURE DUE TO SEVERE
ANEMIA AFTER BEING TREATED IN A
HOSPITAL.
AFTER SUFFERING FROM AN UNKNOWN
ILLNESS.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT DID NOT
RESPOND TO WRITTEN QUESTIONS
CONCERNING ALLEGATIONS MADE BY
THE FORMER POLICE OFFICER.
AB DELI LIVES IN NORWAY AND
PUBLISHED CHILDREN'S BOOKS
WRITTEN UYGHUR.
HE INSISTS HE COULD FORGIVE THE
MAN WHO JAILED AND TORTURED HIM.
>> I DON'T HATE THEM.
BECAUSE ALL OF THEM VICTIM OF
THIS SYSTEM.
>> IF YOU MET ONE OF THESE
PRISONERS, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
THEM?
>> I'M SCARED.
I WOULD LEAVE IMMEDIATELY.
>> WHY?
>> HOW DO I FACE THESE PEOPLE?
YOU'D FEEL GUILTY EVEN IF YOU'RE
JUST A SOLDIER.
YOU'RE STILL RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHAT HAPPENED.
YES, YOU NEED TO EXECUTE ORDERS,
BUT SO MANY PEOPLE D